what's up army
I'm Greg I'm John Cooke Saturday's BTS
time that's what has happened with this
channel subconsciously hey we're gonna
watch BTS heartbeat
BTS bro OST this is a topper wardrobe
video request from Natalie Doran the
woman who got us on the path to the BTS
journey founder of bangtan Saturdays it
wasn't for her we would not be covering
so much BTS so you make sure to thank
her here's what she told me this is a
music video for the BTS game only there
was a BTS game on which console you get
to become their manager and you make
them debut there's a lot of clips in the
game I don't know it sounds weird
it's like a business game yeah
entertainment right now I feel like
there should just be like a dance
central or a team fight or seven members
fight and then fight black pink or
something
hello yeah over our patreon page we do
weekly q and A's and TV show reaction
stream along some reaction highlights
included and John does music video
coverage and you best believe there is
what comes after the letter j h JJ k 1
my initials its age but it's k in real
life why are you so self-absorbed we're
talking about the alphabet k JK pop okay
pop right Wow
don't go to our patreon page
[Applause]
[Music]
baby s been surrounded drives me
[Music]
[Music]
classic couplings
[Music]
I'm pay them in a relationship
[Music]
feel the destiny you feel the destiny me
I'm gonna steal that line
[Music]
[Music]
Reza hey haha universe got now
[Music]
a new trouble
Wow
[Music]
Wow
oh my goodness this woman better be
worth it actually with all these crazy
adventures
[Music]
it's all for a game
[Music]
dude is mr. one helluva game you need to
explore all these words taking BTS I'm
Tony
[Music]
love really connects us all huh right
[Music]
maybe he's talking to the audience
they're talking to the audience
[Music]
oh it's called beats okay look we're
just gonna immediately hop to the game
trailer really quick I gotta see what
that's all about
[Music]
oh my god you're really gonna use them
okay sure came up piteous ah hear that
okay now we need to watch an hour
gameplay on YouTube but walkthrough how
can we get a sponsorship know who we
shout them out at the beginning of a
video that is crazy
those reminded me of when they would
make a game based on a movie mm-hmm and
they will put the likeness of them it's
like a video and not like an actual
animation yeah Street Fighter movie
video game yeah yeah they have like flat
2d for real people yeah I like to think
that would this song all seven of them
are talking to the same person you only
think it's weird girl to this three guys
think about just one girl girl let me
tell you something girl it's not weird
at all in fact girl it's an industry
standard and it happens all the time
it's not seven people seven different
lovers it's one hot-ass woman who's like
45 years hopefully they're obsessing
over like a mother figure to them that's
how I answer but it's not even a
romantic love it's just a nurturing
caring supportive love the kind of love
that sends you out into the world to
sell you know millions upon billions of
multi-platinum that sounds like my kind
of love you ask me plus I mean playing
the game maybe you could learn how to
start your own successful kpop Empire
because it sounds like you're gonna have
to get the boys out on the road you're
gonna have to debut them to all sorts of
people
if this music video is to tie it into
the game at all there could be whole
other worlds you need to debut BTS F I
couldn't tell if these crazy cosmic CGI
spectacle that they did here was in
metaphor to the lyrics specifically or
if it's just because it's called BTS
world official came up piteous as I
think that there's something so
beautiful and so expensive
about what like sci-fi you have you're
in love with this one person destiny and
this is a massive universe but you you
are I universe you know all these hain
to all these planets and stars are all
this cosmic rosado's one summed up into
one entity and that is you love that we
all seven love do they have girlfriends
there's a whole bunch of rumors right
now about like jungkook may be dating
somebody and he maybe got a tattoo but
we don't know I think it was not sure
but yes I believe that there have been
recent rumors about like oh who are some
of them dating I'm just fascinated by
people who sing these brilliant love
songs that you could play for
significant other or have your female
fans or male fans fall in love with you
based off these love songs or them find
out they never are in relationships well
yeah because you know you to pick apart
the love songs and then you realize that
nothing is ever too specific as to
allude to one person I love your hands
because your fingerprints are like no
other and I love you
and their bluish brownish greenish color
I love it when you smile then you smile
wide and I love how your torso as an arm
on either side that's why the Caprio
star of romantic blockbuster hit Titanic
only dates twenty-year-old models he's
got a date he's got a type you can cut
that chain
early on when they want something more
serious like when they want some bTW
also a bang tan but this is really cool
joking army god I know I don't know read
the comments on these BTS videos but I
know what's up whose comments probably
everyone thinks that you hate the band
yeah then why do you keep watching yeah
clearly your disinterest is Greg no I
love the music video I think it's a
beautiful song and I do love the visual
metaphor I just couldn't quite pinpoint
which was it for exactly maybe it's a
connected song to the audience I kind of
said that sarcastically in the middle
reaction but in a sense your perspective
I do think that it could be talking to
the crowd I could see that talking to
the army fan I mean any relationship
song I think unless it goes very far so
as to like clarify this is a romance
between Jews I feel like you can twist
that metaphor around or to resemble any
kind of intimate relationship even one
as distant in a lot of ways is the one
between fans and mega successful artists
made with the BTS world a bit said I
could just text message that whenever I
wanted yeah you know there can't be that
many people on it so you'll probably get
through to one of them or two of them or
three of them at least you know try your
luck
Greg monster I mean see what you can do
they're still waiting for that big break
so yeah well they're waiting for you to
hop on the app and get them out into the
world there wait but as a song I like
the sound of it too because I'm used to
hearing the very sleek synthetic
production and not that this doesn't
have that but I thought they actually
had some more tangible instruments -
that sounds like the drums were maybe a
little live it sounds like there was
maybe some actual guitar in the
background on some of that chorus fun
really heartfelt rap serious yeah so
every time I hear and break out in a rap
I'm like
oh damn listen been dropping these sick
hard yeah damn fire but then he wrapped
him like compassion bars compassion I
bought a compassion bar at my local
7-eleven they don't have those in Korea
no all right guys well tell us did you
get this game is the game worth getting
comment below you guys can subscribe the
real rejects click that notification
bell please and you can check us out on
patreon we have that [ __ ] that we talked
about earlier and nataly door and what
can I say to you man you've been like a
shining ray of sunshine in in the solar
system for us ya know you've done so
much for us however she did tell me that
she briefly was in part of the community
or something with involving this game
and that army fans were just obnoxiously
hitting on her affording with her so she
had to delete her account
really and I said Natalie you brought
that on yourself you know by how you
look that's right you were asking for it
by being a woman maybe instead of
blaming the pervs take a look at
yourselves I'm just attempting the pervs
so don't go outside stay indoors bundle
on your headphones on and listen to some
BTS right leave it at that
these are jokes
oh so Jordan well it's a serious
statement